i'm changing the stream title daily
super blitz arena
it's not every day wesley so is playing
on the chess
um i turned off sound for a moment there
oh so wesley has been berserking and
trying to rampage
oh let's join okay um so the goal is to
catch up to so
which it's going to be difficult to do
i'm tied for last place i'm late joining
i'm in the berserk every game
so this is going to be a bit different
um
no more slow safe
classical chess even though i wasn't
really playing
maybe necessarily safe but i'm gonna be
ultra aggressive
we're gonna play we're gonna start with
um
a nozzle boss gambit oh black's playing
a hippo
f6 let's play this please play g5 please
ah
g5 there's made in one
interesting let's take in bishop g5
no mercy and develop the knights
so given black played f6 uh the king
side's a bit more tender
um that's not a bad move actually never
save the bishop just want to develop and
then
[Music]
eventually make use of the diagonal
maybe queen d5 incoming
or knight d5
or maybe just queen d2 attacking a pawn
okay maybe d7 could be a target
or not oh box defending
i'm still going after this pawn
okay let's take
yeah that's a nice pawn to wing because
now i have access to the g5 square again
i'd be happy to trade bishops debating
whether to take with queen or knight
i'll probably take with queen because of
queenside castle i win the night
i'm also attacking the pawn so that's a
natural move
question do i want to go crazy
oh let's play b4
i don't have much time um let's be safe
let's castle
locks in the castle
guess i'm not getting exactly what i
wanted
and my time ah crush wesley
respectfully i'm trying oh respectfully
922 games oh really
oh maybe you checked chess.com too
interesting
it's good to know
okay looking for tactics
not seeing tactics so i wanted to take
but then
take so i have g4
just trying to chase away the rook not
even threatening to take the rook
but now i am when the rook moves all
i'll win the pawn
so the pawn is pinned threatening this
pawn
if d5 early stream so europeans can
watch bits
oh oh thanks for that okay
now the position's crumbling i have four
attackers against g6
uh i guess i'll take it can trade queens
take this that was probably a blunder
okay king a6 was better there
okay so now we're trading
up five pawns
oh now only four pawns
i have to watch my time
okay pawns go marching
reposition the knight
as this construction is nice because
everything defends everything
covering f3
and keep pushing
that's a time scramble
okay no time to waste
so that that took longer uh than i would
have hoped for
but got the win
yeah i know i know the speedchest
championship is starting but
this oh i forgot to berserk but that's
okay playing a high-rated player
this tournament will be done in an hour
and then i'll probably watch the
scc okay so we have a um
actually critical staffer gambit line
uh bishop c5 threatening this
goal is to play f5 and then f4
f4 is usually the typical plan
i think i have to take and then i'll
play f4
so white's subjectively better but it's
a little bit weird
because there's pressure white's not
really developed i'm castled
there's targets on b2 g3 obviously
my knight's also a target um that's an
interesting move
i'm debating queen f6 actually
which i think i'll play
the idea is if i lose the night i win
the rook
and there's there's now options of
moving the queen over
um i would have liked to take
unfortunately yeah that's not doable
let's play g6
so i'm threatening to take and win f3
ooh this white stacking back
um i guess i'll cash in
[Music]
wow a fancy moot
wants to play bishop c4 i'll prevent it
and doesn't really prevent it but
[Music]
i could play g2 here
play g2 keeping the h file closed
now let's go for b6
also considering taking taking might be
safer king h8
f3 is hanging if white defends f3 i play
knight f4 securing g2
that's a weird position very sharp
opposite side castling
a little bit down on time there's equal
material
uh put the rook in the center
d5 might be coming
that's a decent move something about
horsey
okay let's take
now c6 i mean we might end up trading
queens oh or i just lose a pawn
huh it's kind of
irritating
can play b5 problem b5 rook d7
oh there's a cool idea though
oh there's a really cool idea
i'm gonna go for it oh i'm down on time
so i'm allowing rook d7 and the idea is
to play b4
sac h7 and then just king never mind
start with let's start with b4 playing
very recklessly here
i just want a smothered mate somehow
it's not happening though there's a
trick rook d6 never mind
i'll go after the e pawn
i didn't even berserk this game i'm so
down on time
i'll play g5 securing the knight
white's knight is still pinned
down two pawns
i'll try and advance my majority on the
king's side
bring the king to e5 maybe
interesting move
a very difficult position with the time
situation
there we go that's the fork
hmm
i'm so nervous
ah that was a really bad move only
tricked me
let's go dirty flag let's go i won that
somehow
i won that somehow oh wow i feel dirty
opponent tried to flag me i was down so
much time
how much time was i down oh it's another
game started
berserk i was down
i mean it was four seconds so 44 seconds
man okay no time to waste life goes on
let's go
heart was beating
okay uh huh i'm still kind of shaking
palms are sweaty mom's spaghetti okay
let's play
aggressively i guess play this move
knight g5 coming going for the quick win
oh wesley so in second place
i've only played two games so far
and that last game felt like an eternity
okay i want a triple fork it's my life
goal
my g5 could be some interesting idea but
let's go
let's go yeah
life gets dirty sometimes
okay still ideas of winning the pawn
or not
some g4 knight c5 is still in the air
now the bishop's now kind of more active
rook d7 might as well throw in rook d7
i'm gonna have to take with pawn
oh i have knight d6 wait i might be
just be winning the queen 96
i didn't calculate this but i hope it
works
it better work
not sure
it's a cool line okay opponent doesn't
go for it so i win the queen
oh and the bishop's still hanging that's
beautiful so i'm gonna be up a queen
[Music]
oh i'm gonna win the knight two there we
go
rook d1 i have rook f1
black is still fighting
[Music]
going after this pawn
now this pawn
it's a little bit annoying
the rooks are tied down to each other
i mean they want to coordinate against
each two but it's difficult
i should close my tabs
there we go okay some more tabs
okay now i just want to push the pawns
there is rook b7 i guess on rook b1
[Music]
or even queen c3
okay queen c3 pin and win
rook d7 i'll play
uh probably work team one
okay that's three wins
trying to move up in the world top 200
let's go
hundred players playing this playing
death note
staffer gambit time maybe
okay stafford declined
um bishop e3 is a kind of positional
mistake
um we'll see what black which way black
wants to count or white wants a castle
i probably want to castle this way make
it sharp
uh it's a decent move so there's a few
plans here
one plan is to go after the pawn um our
plan would be to attack somehow
um
[Music]
i could trade too maybe i'll trade first
and then pile up
there's a problem for white this pawn is
backwards
on the half open file
play f6 i'm threatening to take
there's queen g4 play c6 it's hard for
the pawn to advance
okay now i'm gonna allow i allow queen
f5
but i think it's okay
there's a cool line uh takes takes queen
f5 king b8
takes and then here here here queen f2
in the end
rook g1 rook e1 i think is winning
okay we're not going into that play rook
d7
so now this is no no longer check
blockade the pawn
okay let's defend
[Music]
how to defend
you start by checking preventing any
rook move
got to move a lot quicker here
time is so precious
nice position though
okay the h5 want to go for the pawn
storm
i am weakening f6
play this move first
take a free queen
plenty of time
okay let's go i'm just trying to catch
wesley it's my only goal in life
ah he's so strong so
so strong
and he lost his first game and then just
went on a rampage
so i'm oh i'm top hundred eighty-seven
okay making progress
okay playing shasta 93. zurich let's
play london
mix it up a little bit
london versus kings indian this is more
of a pierce
opening
i can take that
um i think f3 is probably the go-to move
e5 is a very very typical idea
and there's a cool idea knight h5 i play
bishop e3 with a double threat of
winning the knight because of the pin
but also trapping the knight because it
would have no squares
um pretty sure i show this in my london
course
at least a similar idea
that's a nice tactic
actually had this in a tournament game
once too
yeah so the night is uh restricted
pawn is still pinned kind of i guess we
could trade
okay let's develop b5 bishop d5
um i could trade queens
trade queens i'm going after this pawn
no need to oh okay that's a free queen
opponent saw this threat but not that
threat okay 15 move win that was nice
34th place 20 points
what's my favorite opening oh london or
stafford
i've played yeah most of my games have
been london or stafford this tournament
oh okay this is a cool line i prepared
this specifically
for uh augustine um
in norway or uh in denmark augustine's
from norway
uh it's been a while since i looked at
this so
there's some e4 move
i don't have so much time a queen d3
first and then preparing
there's some like interesting thematic
ideas
with this sort of thing
okay c5 is logical
oh
wanted to do tactics let's take first
thinking this but then knight d7
i mean there's takes and then this and
then this knight has to move
okay let's castle i want to go for e4
it's gonna get sharp
it's gonna get very sharp
i mean e4 d4 e5 takes takes takes
and takes i don't know what's going on
bishop here maybe
oh thanks so much i appreciate that
crazy jude st
appreciate it very much
okay so i'm just going into this hoping
it's not too bad for
me
um it's going to get messy actually d4
there's knight a4 as well
and then attack the bishop and threaten
[Music]
e5
okay just trusting my intuition here
it could be off
yeah i'm kind of regretting this
because my knight is lacking squares
oh this is probably just really bad for
me c4
oh this is really bad
i have to play c4 and knight b4 there's
queen b3
and the hope is that we we trade and my
knight gets back
but that's no guarantee meanwhile my
time is
kind of suffering
okay that's kind of what i wanted oh
okay
it's definitely a relief
i'm not out of danger
bones moving very slowly probably
playing this for time
at this point can be
two safe move bishop will sit happily
or we might just trade actually
rook d a probably king c3
yeah i think i'm gonna win on time
if black continues at this pace
oh castling surprise move let's defend
so i want to play this preventing rook
d8
preparing this and then maybe this
also f4
um
[Music]
let's defend oh my time
ah that was a mouse slip pulling ahead
rook b5
tricky tricky
what is this okay one time i was going
for the mate towards the end there
okay 21st place
what's your favorite type of pumpkin pie
or american pie
i don't know
one berserk point is not worth risking
four fire points against strong players
uh i don't know but like the only way to
catch wesley is to
[Music]
i need a big net or rope i don't know
oh this is a risk please berserk back
please
opponents not berserking back okay to
play fast
okay and go for the minority attack
b5 or a5
what am i doing with my life here
it's a good move
i have to be very very careful here
this is terrifying um
don't hurt me oh h7 was hanging or h2
[Music]
please don't hurt me
okay this is confusing now
what is this some kind of dark magic
i do have e5
it's interesting because i unleash the
bishop well i wanted to play this move
but then i take
if it takes time looks like i'm getting
mated but i actually win a queen
and if takes takes it's a discovered
fork
what does this move that's a very clever
move
i do have a bishop f8
i could also consider
taking
taking just loses though play bishop f8
it's such a weird position i should not
have bizarre
so the plan is to play e5
again if takes takes
white has four attackers i have a single
bishop defending
oh that's a great move
i have no idea what to do here to defend
the queen
so it takes takes trying to count
so i have enough defenders f4
oh oh that's a good move
i'm getting crushed now there goes all
my position
okay i resigned that was really rough
but no time to waste there's still 40
minutes left
maybe wesley has a so-so internet oh
so-so
[Music]
ah i should have listened to uh whoever
told me
to be careful berserking against strong
players
that's okay wesley lost a game too so
we're
we still have i mean not quite the same
score
but at least that was a quick loss quick
and painful
oh thanks for subbing thanks everyone
for subbing if i
didn't mention your name i'm a little
bit busy okay going for this stuff
okay opponent's playing very safe let's
play aggressive
we have a reverse philidor defense
or reverse hungarian maybe
um i like the position
put the queen here
oh i'm kind of losing a pawn
but why didn't i could have taken and
taken
oh no oh i just blundered terribly
okay why could have trapped my queen
that would have been really bad so i
have to take
your opponent is in chat oh really oh
i guess that's good to know case they're
listening to potential clues
what do i do here
okay this time i'm not blundering a
queen
um play c5
you're going for positional play
very positional nice pawn on d3
e4 is kind of weak you can put the
bishop here
and it's like moses crossing the the c
play this move
um what is this position
i have no idea what to do also have no
time
you put the queen here
difficult situation
i have to push hope for the best
and down the exchange
still some hope though
yes i got a structure
there we go okay that's exactly what i
wanted
um this should be winnable
should be very winnable
the key is to put the pawns on dark
squares and cover light squares with the
bishop
and rook has no no life no offense
okay that's a nice finish
okay okay that was nice i was
i was in trouble i was had the worst
position in the long time
opponent fought well okay i'm gonna
continue
being aggressive and berserking i'll
play an ortho schnapp
orthodontic time someone was asking how
to attack the french earlier
this is a cool line because you get an
open position against a french player
french player is usually like closed
positions
oh this is actually i think this is a
main line
if i'm not mistaken like here and then
takes
okay now probably the plans to take
eventually on on d3 but also develop
it's a little bit awkward with the queen
oh that's interesting
i feel like my opponent's prepared
getting the vibe play this move
okay probably 95 some discovery maybe
start with 95 just applying pressure
some cool bishop c5 idea
i have knight f6 i'll play bishop c5
not move probably have to trade
so i'm still down a pawn but
i mean there's compensation with the
files i'm sacking this pawn
very brave decision for my opponent
so i could take here when then so
winning back upon
keeping initiative activating further
if here i win the knight with bishop e6
now the bishop's pinned
threatening this maybe
um i think i'll start with this
oh thanks for the bits g spates
appreciate that
or not g space js 100 sd
and g space was a the message below
let's take this pawn
so now the bishop is very still pinned
i wanna oh this so it's a cool oh the
pawn's defended by the thing
well i'm threatening this which it's a
fork
plus a pin so it's a pork
oh and if if there i play i play this
anyway
and if takes i it's close to mating
actually
but still yeah it's still a little bit
confusing
but since you called that what
not sure what that meant but i have to
um
have to focus the ortho
save the thing
this is very tense
debating whether it's a sack don't think
i'll sack
oh it's gonna be a grind
f3 probably rook d4 f3
maybe i should have played f4 should
have played that for
okay so the whole idea is to
is to meet let's go
okay oh yeah it's all about getting the
knight to h7
that was reflex okay that's good points
double berserking broad fraud fraud
fraud
fraud fraud foreign um
it's not fraud if it's the truth right
okay let's play this so we're going into
this line this stuff online queen c4
takes yeah i enjoy this line
97 and f5
rookie 8 bishop usually likes to go
maybe rookie 6's natural move bishop
likes to come back here
combined with king b7
i could get a 75 pawn cube
play this move piling up on the pawn
i'm just running to take
oh there's a cool line knight e4 i take
with the rook
um i can win the pawn right takes takes
takes
let's do it
this is working out very nicely we could
actually trade into a
kingpin ending
just pray hard enough
um this should be winning just takes a
little bit of work
i mean most king pawn endings where
you're up oh
did i mess up i may have messed up
ah
wait a minute let's calculate
there there
i think a4 first
and c5 c6 this idea to be careful here
okay
um the tricky position
[Music]
might have some weird things happening
i may have messed up
okay why should i play a4 there
let's go
okay i think i was losing at some point
but okay it was a time scramble
top 10 let's go the goal is to pass
maybe it's going to be hard to catch
wesley
um but let's keep it up
28 minutes left budapest gambit declined
pleasant opening let's play d5
aggressive move
um 894
another aggressive move piling up on the
pinned piece
d4 not quite working
let's take that
so basically getting an end game with
the bishop hair
might want to take and play knight e5
that's going to be an end game grind
i mean i like having the bishop pair
though
okay let's trade rooks
i might win the a pawn in the end
yeah i think i'm winning the pawn
because i can always take
regardless of what happens
amy is stuck at rating 1250 how can i
improve to something like
1500
uh tactics tactics tactics tactics
play slower games too
you'll learn more from the slower games
okay i'm up two pawns i have three
connected passers on the queen side
minor pieces are here for some emotional
support
i trapped the bishop bishop's almost
trapped actually
it's weird but where does the bishop go
bishop here here and here here
i guess i was here in c5
well that's interesting i can i can take
it's a fancy line
double attack there's knight here and
then i'll
take the rook and push upon
hmm improve the night
also attacking the rook
my pawn ah opponent doesn't take it
okay
um
[Music]
what am i doing here
i kind of messed up
i'm gonna have to pre-move a lot of
moves here
i should not have lost the pawn
but that's okay position still winnable
so the strategy is to win
that was tricky to cover each four
strategies to win the um h3 pawn
there we go richie and i take it
that's why board vision is so important
okay let's go wow wesley has more than
double the points of me
man wesley's probably winning the games
faster
that's rough it's going to take a lot of
work to catch up
it's probably just impossible at this
point
there's a cool trap um okay not going to
happen here
whatever that means uh what's
the line here can i save the pawn maybe
this move
so the goal is to hold on to the pawn is
it's kind of weak but also defended
enough times
the bishop probably wants to develop
plant itself
on a nice square
that's an interesting position if i can
win the pawn it's a nice positional game
for black
but for the time being i'm defending the
pawn
and i control a lot of space in black's
territory
at the right moment i might uh might
want to play d6
but no reason to right now
um gotta move quick
not sure what g4 does but uncover f5
and kingside's not vulnerable
offering the trade i think f6 hurts
black more than it helps
blocks a bishop weakens the pawn and the
square
if we trade i'll be very happy
i guess we'll trade bishop
[Music]
to play maybe queen e2 some idea of
pushing
f on again if we trail on e5 i'm happy
to undouble my pawns
i'm actually threatening to take and
then win the e pawn or opponent sees it
there's a lot of tension here
f5 would be still kind of a cool move
or f4 f4 i trap my own bishop
let's triple up now i have a gun
on the e-file threatening to take and
take
um have to move
so pawn can't be taken because of night
hangs
wait what
am i seeing this correctly i think i am
now f7 is vulnerable
e6 i take and there's a pin
okay so i can take on f7 first
and take here i don't even have to take
the knight queen e5 coming okay
that was nice got the berserking points
against a decently high rated player
oh wesley so is paused is wesley
so retired from chess can i catch wesley
soweth
as less than 21 minutes left
windsteak most delicious type of steak
more delicious than the ham steak
okay keep trying to win quickly
london time now we have kind of a
mainline london
now this is very mainline black has a
bunch of options this
is the most critical move um
b1 going into some theory here
and bishop d7 i'm not sure about
wow okay this is new for me
first impressions to take i think this
should be good because
if takes i take on b7
um though i'm not sure actually
let's do it no time to to ponder
oh there's a cool line c6 and if takes i
win the rook
because discover check
now i take here opening the file
i'm preventing black from casting
because the king's tied down to
defending the bishop let's pile up
and it's a nice construction bishop is
fiance
black's territory
um play rook b5
i want to play f5 at the right moment
so just building up more pressure
controlling so many squares in black's
territory
that five is a main idea so winning
material
or is it rookie eight
i guess rookie yet i just take it
um slightly confusing position
this defends both knights
now c7
i was pretty sure i could take here
oh oh i kind of messed up
i can take the bishop though it's
complicated
um my time
[Music]
i mean it's still better but i spent a
lot of time there
okay going after the pawn
check
oh dear what did i do
oh this is so bad
no i'm getting mated ah the position is
so good too
rage pause
it was such a nice position i just
allowed
rookie eight it's still probably winning
somehow
i was really unfortunate it was
overconfident
i don't think wesley so is returning
i'll try and finish
i don't know top something
so much rage i haven't felt so angry in
a while oh opponents berserking back
okay
that's nice so opponent's playing a caro
khan reverse
or whatever this is
okay hippo hippo time
hungry hippo
take the knight let's be safe
control the center b5 i'll just calmly
move back
turning the pawn
that's a good move
that's a really weird game so far
a really strange opening
um i don't like the way i'm playing this
yeah this is
i'm not proud of this at all
but i have to live with my bad decisions
i'm gonna try and untangle
[Music]
it's like one of those um seeing this
video of a sea lion
it got stuck in some sort of plastic and
it had to like
find its way out
and that's how i feel right now play
this move
still stuck though it didn't do anything
let's trade
probably c6 at some point
it's a good move skewer
that's a skewer
no okay opponent missed a good move
opponent missed a really good move let's
try and orchestrate some mating idea
where's my mate
ah
you
oh let's go oh i feel so dirty
i feel so dirty i was losing the whole
game wow
opponent beat me with a weird opening
but didn't actually beat me
because dirty flag oh i feel so dirty
okay
imrozen don't flag him rose and don't
flag him yeah i need to
flag him rose and don't flag him rose
and don't flag oh thanks for telling me
now
i need to buy some silver rage pause
bits
the rage pause yeah reducing the rage
with the dirty flags
okay double berserk and play c3
building the triangle illuminati oh
bishop a6 is winning
this is in my london course this is a
secret novelty
it used to be a novelty but now it's uh
i've had this many times online
it's a nice idea so i'm attacking the
pawn and now i
take the knight and attack everything
um yeah this is probably the best line
what did i show i think i showed this in
my
my course the london is getting old
sorry
it never gets old i think i show this
exact line in the course and i take
um the king is dragged out
there's a cool line here here here and
then triple fork
happy friday three
that was nice that was really nice i was
feel good especially against a high
rated player
thank you bob valentine solving for 11
months
and berenson chess so 52 points
trying to finish top three yeah wesley
unfortunately is uncatchable
yeah he's just mad he forgot to berserk
one game i guess
okay he's working again i'm pre-movie
opponent is following levy's e4 course
wash your mouse with soap for flagging
so much do you kiss your mother with
that mouse
um i use a mouse to
what no comments okay um
let's take and win material
i like the fact my opponent's berserking
i'll always play f6 want to open that
file
or win a pawn
i'm giving this pawn oh that's tricky
play this move opponent unleash the
diagonal via c3
i'm gonna play this move
h6
a point is trying to squeeze me
not the most pleasant feeling
okay that's what i wanted now
now my position has some breathing room
happy to trade into some endgame
could have taken the pawn okay
simplifying a little bit further
the bishop's pan was pinned to the rook
activate
ah let's check from behind
[Music]
okay the king is very weirdly placed
looks very amazable
[Music]
attack a pawn the opponent saw my
devious threat so the goal is to
go is to somehow checkmate
oh that's a good move oh that's actually
a really good move
am i in trouble
wow i'm in a little bit of trouble here
takes i think this is okay
i didn't really plan for this but it's
okay
okay it worked out in the end
okay berserking e4 time
haven't played this opponent yet we'll
play a grand prix setup
this could be one of my last games
so the bishop goes back d5 will be met
with e5
we have to prevent black from playing a4
and black's playing well so far
doing the typical things the black's
supposed to do in the structure
to defend this pawn
another good move
yeah usually white wants to attack but i
kind of have to babysit my queen side
okay now i get some attacking potential
unleashing the bishop
and maybe the knight can move in
i want to play this
okay let's do it
there's some risk involved but it's
risky for black too
i'm still allowing this to be captured
the thought is that the rook comes to b1
interesting play f6
is at some point e5 will hang
yeah there we go unleashing the rook
and now yeah now this pawn is undefended
too so it's a double attack
just going for the quick attack
so the queen oh do i have a cool
of almost a cool move
i'll start with improving the bishop
i was thinking rook f5 might take a
little bit of preparation
we've got five takes
i'm not sure if it works so i'm gonna
play safe and just
gradually keep improving the pieces
um i can't resist it's it's too
appetizing
it might just be bad but it looks fun
knight h5 to f6
that looks like a lot of fun
rook g8 expected
i mean the plan is very simple just to
mate
black's piece is not really defending
thanks for subbing
khan khan science something and run tune
this move i think i'm completely winning
now
remembering chicago blaze days your
streams are both new and fresh and very
nostalgic for me
oh i appreciate that welcome oh i
probably know you in real life
uh i really appreciate that
but i can't get distracted
okay it's very important that the bishop
is uh is covering b1
and after it takes i check and then
win stuff probably takes some takes
blocks considering or yeah black's
probably considering this move
and then i can throw in the check intake
okay that was nice so maybe time for one
more game
i'm i'm close to catching lazy cat
i just need to play one more berserk win
lazy cat's also playing though oh lazy
cat's winning too
[Music]
okay i'll still try and finish strong
and thank you argso subbing with prime
yeah chicago blaze i was back during
uh the us chess league before the pro
chess league
it was the first online league i
competed in
um play bishop b3
safe and solid
okay playing solid chess
to always watch my time
ah that's a fair move what to do
[Music]
d5 d5 is probably typical here but
there's also some crazy let's be crazy
the threats this and having fun
and this is probably really bad oh or
really good
yeah it's really good let's go
[Music]
opponent thought i just wanted to trade
it's taken d6 is now attacked
oh but mine okay so if takes i take here
okay pawn is rolling uh we'll take and
then fork
this should work tactically
[Music]
yeah this definitely works okay oh time
for maybe one more game
so lazy cat also won
one more game come on less than two
minutes left
let's go berserk please work back please
have to go for it have to go for it
ah opponent's not doing it
i went for it though i tried it it
didn't work
okay so now i just have to suffer down
upon
h6 at some point
okay i still want to win in the next
minute
but it's going to be tough i should have
played this move
i can still play this move threatening
to take and check and win the bishop
let's go i'm going to win the bishop
please resign please
upon's not going to resign
how do i prompt resignation
[Music]
to go for some attack um
okay this is cool f4 queen g3 queen
jake's e5 rook d2 winning
ah but we're not going into it
um
[Music]
okay let's just play this and win the
pawn
takes on e7 counting takes takes f4 mate
um
ah it's not gonna finish in time but
okay i'll convert this
it'll still be a nice finish
hopefully assuming i don't screw up
so there's a few targets here i'm
controlling f3 so there's no rook f3
um probably just want to go after the
pawn expecting rookie one
oh rookie one there's a cool move knight
f3
it's interesting
[Music]
i want to do tactics but nothing seems
to work
i have to move quicker make loot for the
king
control the file and white's kind of
stuck
too
okay so i'm going to win the pawn
going after this pawn now
or not
moving way too slowly
the f5 oh wait i have the same tactic
yeah it's removed it's a fork and
removal of the garden
okay plenty of time
force the queen trade go after the pawns
yeah so the rook will gobble up the
pawns and then
the rest of the game can be pre-moved
okay that was nice it was nice
tournament
[Music]
so i joined late i lost
i lost two games have a lot of berserk
wins
there is one game i forgot to berserk
that uh second game
but uh yeah wesley so
and wesley so like uh he maybe the last
time he played was
in one of these like super saint louis
tournaments on leech us
um thanks everyone for watching fun
tournament
played a lot of like super aggressive
chess a lot different from the
the slow chest that i started with a lot
of dirty time scrambles
and probably end up putting this whole
thing on youtube
so youtube people thanks for watching if
you made it this far
let me know in the comments and if you
want to watch live you can follow on
twitch
and get notified when i go live